[Music]
oh my goodness oh my god i can't believe
it holy cow patricia birds you are so
beautiful
oh my goodness
you came from me i came for you patricia
bird we know your story we fell in love
with you
and we wanted to come meet you and
celebrate you and tell you how much you
inspire us
now if you don't mind i don't can i uh
walk you outside really quickly you are
[Applause]
[Music]
i can't believe she's here get y'all all
this is so wonderful
it took drew barrymore coming to texas
to get you all in my presence i've not
seen you all continued this is my
lawrence and you did you meet lauren i
certainly did that's my missy what's it
like to have a mom that you're so proud
of yeah
just watching her like just shine her
light amongst all of these kids and
fellow her colleagues it's just been
amazing
how do you tell yourself that you can do
all the things that you want to do and
take care of everybody else it's called
grace
if you don't extend it to yourself you
won't get it from anywhere else not an
easy road to travel especially when you
are
type a personality what's something we
can tell ourselves to go out there and
be bigger better stronger people begin
the day in quiet contemplation
decide what it is that you want to
accomplish within the 24 hours that are
granted you and work hard to check the
list off and for everything else that
just give yourself grace those things
that you did not accomplish draw that
hour to the next day and tackle it the
next
day i feel
like um
i want to change my life starting
tomorrow morning in honor of you
patricia byrne and live the rest of my
life
to
your standards and you do you have so
much to teach us and i'm so lucky to be
a beneficiary of your wisdom
because i am just one of so many that
feel that way
you barrymore hugged me oh my god
i never would have expected in a million
years i might even call it bird time
i was just so excited to also meet your
community for all the things for which
you would applaud me we've got to
celebrate them too because they've
influenced who i am so can i clap can i
clap for this
thank you reggie thank y'all so much
missy
by the way i have a sign too
[Applause]
tractor supply is the largest rural
lifestyle retailer and is passionate
about ensuring that all kids have a safe
place to play and grow which is why they
want to give plumber elementary 20 000
to rebuild a state-of-the-art playground
oh my goodness look
a playground for plumbers
[Applause]
is it true that you're a fan of chip and
joanna oh my god oh they're in my head
they're my best friends we're friends do
you want to come to waco with me to meet
them
[Applause]
i'm going to share time with chip and
joanna we're going to go to waco and see
chip and joe but in the meantime do you
mind if i send you and lawrence on a
vacation we are going to send you and
lawrence to the playa largo resort in
florida
a five night luxurious getaway at playa
larga resort and spa in the beautiful
florida keys i'm a better person for
meeting you
everyone's a better person for meeting
you it is such a pleasure to meet all of
you guys thank you for letting me be a
part of this moment
[Music]
you